so we're gonna do the first-ever NDC  security in Australia on the Gold Coast  [Music]  and the Gold Coast is an epic location  to go to plus we're gonna do my hack  yourself first workshop which I reckon  is an epic workshop to go to so we're  gonna spend a lot of time doing things  like sequel injection cross-site  scripting looking at all sorts of  different web security attacks and most  importantly because this is very  orientated to people who are building  and delivering systems we're gonna talk  a lot about how to defend them so we're  gonna look at what are the right  patterns and practices to use to keep  your apps safe from the hackers and you  get to do it on the gold coast as well  which is the best possible spot in the  world to do